this way go to the far right door
[Music]
watch your step right here please
the movement will not rest until we get
justice for all of these ferrets right
now I appreciate it of everybody coming
out it just hurts a lot just being here
this talk
despaigne
thank you all so much for coming out the
supporter and all the families that here
with me today Michael Brown Eric one
grow
[Applause]
we love you George we know it's working
y'all wouldn't know but to give you one
thing about him again he's a family man
great man he stands for the definitely
simple man because we didn't have no
[ __ ] growing up and my brother all the
steps he did as a human being as a young
teenager and it makes so much sense now
to me as I'm older and understood that
the stuff you were doing with teaching
there's lessons later we're still here
Baddeley I stand in solidarity with his
family because it mimics my case and
this is personal to me
they have doubled back and claimed
another night by a chokehold we talked
to the district attorney's office and
they notified us that they had asked for
increase in the bail amount for officer
Derek Chauvin and I'm proud to tell BJ
and Rodney his family here at this
moment that the bear was increased to
1.5 in jail any protesters that have
been arrested for peaceful protesting we
want you to drop all the charges
immediately
you